oh
présenté dans cette unité où l'on
retrouve l'élite du football français
25 % de l'emploi du temps est consacré à
des exercices bien connue en particulier
les défilés au pain ou encore le
traditionnel parcours du combattant près
de 250000 appelés du contingent parce
que déjà entre qui sont 27 de haut
niveau ou des gens qui ont déjà un
métier
et qui doivent rendre une année à
l'armée c'est vrai que ça peut poser
problème maintenant c'est pour tout le
monde pareil on est bien obligé de
donnez set avant de donner cette année
d'armer une année au cours de laquelle
il a radu et les autres continuent
d'exercer leur métier de footballeur
environ quatre heures d'entraînement par
jour sous l'autorité d'un technicien
réputé et à forte personnalité